Warsaw Poland is home to some delicious
dishes like stab over pretty good
pierogi hmm and one sec yes and this
pigs feet in jelly look at the way it's
wobbling just just wobbles
this is mushy Fogle RHA translated to
English it means pigs feet in jelly yes
that's a pig's foot in jelly this
traditional Polish dish has been served
for over a hundred years Barbara has
been whipping up the dish for family
occasions for decades that's because she
thinks pigs feet in jelly is well
[Music]
machine-independent symbols of Apple and
in the schooners personal a triple-a an
obscure machine technically no second at
all subsidies potentia doctrine is Ruby
wash machine minion adoption scam or
Salvage thanks Barbara it's claimed that
the first meat jelly dishes were served
in 1518 at a wedding feast of an old
polish king and queen back then
pork wasn't so popular so it was served
with either young chickens or even fish
here in central Warsaw it's on the menu
breck is the head chef he knows the
recipe by heart
chairman punto tombo gara no scribsy
golonka
Vaslav are rich cloud objects a proper
go to mmm Pardo Dugan our noble DiMaggio
sister Regina King cream mezkappa Java
Java vomitus coffee varam those teenage
host of yummy
post anguish must encourage it a taste
of the Synod an emotional Sabarsky was
me yes
[Music]
the muzhik garage is this was my latest
schmuck we're blue vodka okay but what's
the deal with the jelly revival Galaga
so it's the proteins from the bones back
and now the most important part the
taste
[Music]
you